let's talk a little bit about Donald
Trump and this interesting dynamic where
many of the accusations that Trump makes
against Hillary Clinton actually end up
applying to Donald Trump himself right
Trump accuses Hillary Clinton of being
involved in pay-to-play
it seems actually he's involved in some
really really major pay-to-play
Trump accuses Hillary Clinton of being
involved in sketchy financial dealings
and it turns out that Donald Trump's
Trump University is the subject of
multiple investigations and lawsuits for
scamming people and it appears to be all
based on a completely bogus
representations about what it is you
will learn at Trump University
Trump accuses the Clinton Foundation of
being a corrupt organization meant to
prop up Hillary Clinton's political
power and it appears that the donald
trump foundation is exactly the same
thing misusing supposed charity
donations for strategic political gain
and the the big news over the last 24
hours is we have learned that the New
York Attorney General Eric Schneiderman
has opened an investigation into the
Trump foundation after numerous media
outlets including our program have been
reporting on the very very clear misuse
of charity donations to the Trump
foundation for political purposes this
includes the donations we talked about
last week and this week to Florida
Attorney General Pam Bondi 'he's
reelection campaign for the purposes of
making the Trump University
investigation go away Rachel told us
last week that Trump was indeed fined by
the IRS $2,500 for that and that is
indeed true and now we know that New
York Attorney General Eric Schneiderman
said his office is indeed looking into
the Trump foundation and whether or not
they complied with state laws he says
his interest and a quote is my interest
in this issue really is in my capacity
as regulator of nonprofits in New York
State and we have been concerned that
the Trump foundation may have engaged in
some impropriety from that point of view
what is the Donald Trump campaign say
about this exactly what you would expect
they're dismissing this as a left-wing
hit job but there are some real concerns
here we had this
port over the weekend showing that
Donald Trump hasn't contributed to his
own charity since 2008 we found out that
the foundation made donations to
charities with contributions made by
other people so other people's money is
being donated in this tax-deductible way
to the Trump Foundation and then the
money is being used for Donald Trump's
political posturing and positioning and
as I mentioned Trump recently had to pay
this twenty five hundred dollar penalty
uh Donald Trump reorganized the entire
charity to be able to spend other
people's money and there are some really
concerning comments that we've heard
about the foundation his but new
co-manager Kellyanne Conway actually
said hey what's the big deal
this is Donald Trump's money it's really
not in two different ways number one
Trump hasn't donated to his own
foundation since 2008 but even more
importantly uh this is not your money
the whole point of establishing a
non-profit in this way is that it is not
just your personal money to do whatever
you want with their very specific rules
this is so disturbing to me Rachel
because it is yet another way in which
Donald Trump is the epitome of the owner
of a glasshouse who just stands outside
throwing stones at everybody else it's
really good that this is being looked
into but by and large I doubt we are
going to see any significant penalty and
and that $2,500 IRS fine
I mean it's completely laughable to a
guy who's worth depending on Huebel who
you believe between two and ten billion
dollars it's not enough to offset the
benefits of of buying people with with
donations well what he stands to gain
right now in terms of how he can kind of
buy support and buy followers for making
these inappropriate donations is going
to be a lot a lot larger than these kind
of small slap on the wrists he's getting
for what he's doing no doubt about it
and we often talk about when it comes to
white-collar type crime very often
number one the institution ends up
getting punished rather than the
individuals that's number one so many
times the individuals completely avoid
any kind of repercussions whatsoever but
very often the benefit that you stand to
gain by by taking these actions far
outweighs the
ability of a fine which you may not even
actually be assessed so it's great that
Eric Schneiderman is looking into this
it's abundantly clear that he should
because this is a racket that Donald
Trump is running but but the idea that
all of a sudden everything Trump's doing
is going to be blown up it's just not
going to happen because the legal
infrastructure just isn't there send me
your thoughts about this on Twitter at D
Pakman Warby Parker is offering a free
five day home Tryon to give you the
opportunity to check out their glasses I
personally wear Warby Parker glasses
when I'm not wearing my contact lenses
and I also started with one of these
free at home try ons of five pairs of
glasses you can get your free home try
on and support the david pakman show at
Warby Parker trialed dot-com slash TDP s
I don't really like going into glasses
stores and trying on glasses while the
sales person sort of hovers over me and
I like more than 30 seconds to actually
figure out whether I like the glasses so
with the Warby Parker home Tryon I was
able to pick five pairs that I liked put
them on in the comfort of my own home
pick the one I liked the most and then
Warby Parker put my prescription lenses
in there for me a lot of people don't
know that the eyeglass industry is
controlled by just a few big
corporations that keep prices very high
like $300 for prescription glasses hi
which is just insane Warby Parker
glasses start at $95 that's what mine
cost and for every pair of glasses sold
Warby Parker distributes a pair of
glasses to someone in need
you can try five pairs and see what you
like check out the at home trial and
support our show by going to Warby
Parker dot-com slash TDP s it costs
nothing